well intelligence in both senses of the
word should play a major role in
presidential decision-making provided
and had intelligence with a capital high
coming from the intelligence agencies of
the United States is reliable and
careful and is accurately conveyed and
interpreted by the president when he
receives that intelligence it helps to
have intelligence in the other sense of
the word in the Oval Office John F
Kennedy was an extremely intelligent
president and kicked himself that he
relied on mistaken intelligence without
questioning further and without having
his brother Bobby and me in the room to
question further those who sold him on
the Bay of Pigs invasion on the basis of
one false premise after another
there was no uprising in the Q Lo and
the Exile landed how could there be most
of Castro's opponents were either in
Miami or jail there was no opportunity
for the Exile to fall back into the s
cambree Mountains when their invasion
failed how could they that was miles and
miles away from the landing point how
could there be secrecy as to the u.s.
role in that invasion which they had
promised him when they had their own
public relations office in New York and
the Cuban exiles in Florida were leaking
to the New York Times and others all the
information about the plans that excited
them in fact exaggerating their leaks so
that Castro thought is going to be an
even bigger and
and had an even bigger army there to
meet them I've always thought that the
CIA's motto ought to be often wrong but
never in doubt getting assurances from
the CIA means very little until you
review the underlying National
Intelligence Estimates and a president
ought to have people in charge of CIA
who are professionals who are
scrupulously honest who will not try to
be policymakers and politicians and tell
the president what they think he wants
to hear but who will tell him the facts
good and bad to enable the president to
make the decisions not the CIA after a
while you find out just as a people who
watch television news they soon find out
that they're not getting the straight
facts from Fox News so they turn after a
while to those news channels that
deliver the facts they find out after a
while they're not getting the facts from
certain magazines and newspapers after a
while they discontinue reading those
magazines and newspapers the same is
true in government if you find that your
intelligence services are simply trying
to butter up the loss and give him
soothing reports on successes that turn
out to be failures then giving him
optimistic predictions on actions that
turn out to be disasters changed the
people at the top after the Bay of Pigs
Kennedy not only changed the people at
the top of the CIA he changed the
procedures by which Intel decisions were
made and the next crisis in Cuba the
Cuban Missile Crisis
had a result totally different from
those early mistakes at the bay of pigs